want to lose weight without drugs pills
or human rights then come to Venezuela
the most effective weight loss solution
in history other diets are unrealistic
regardless of how hard you try your
country still has food but thanks to an
ancient Soviet secret we found a way
here's how our government price controls
leave and they always do - food
shortages leaving you unable to eat late
at night or most other time see that
sounds great
what I miss America please we have
plenty in common you'll still find
yourself standing in line for the latest
release in the Apple Store like ESPN
we've gotten rid of some on-air talent
and we might be getting a Cracker Barrel
look there it is
I'm a journalist Venezuela right for me
of course we have created designated
free speech zones just for you you won't
believe how many calories you'll burn
recycling doing Crossfit and taking
community walks
isn't that a violent protest oh they're
shooting a Pepsi commercial oh that
makes sense
but don't just take my word for it
listen to one of our success stories we
have no toilet paper in front it's okay
because we have no food ha ha ha
when God closes a door he opens a little
it is pie on window learn how you can go
from this to this from this to this from
this well what they've created in
Venezuela is a socialist paradise -
there you had in Venezuela wasn't
technically socialism it was um
Chavez is
Venezuela try it today
[Music]